this is the bismillah hamdullah Salaam
alaikum greetings of peace thank you for
turning into the Dean show is your boss
driving you crazy are you just living
from paycheck to paycheck party to party
and everything is just getting tiring
it's gettin played out and you're asking
yourself what's this all about what's
the purpose many people don't reflect
I'm why am I here you're born to die and
then what do you got in between it's a
big drama some days are good some days
are bad some days you're sick some days
you're sad so we're going to on this
episode of the Dean show answer that
crucial question that I'm glad you're
thinking about what's the purpose what's
it all about life here on the Dean show
with my next guess Imam John we'll be
right back this is the team the biju
this is the thing is the thing
this is the this is the this is the
assalamu alaikum peace be with you i
reccomend celebra to love week a
two-piece blessings and mercy of the
Almighty God be a partner thank you for
joining us Imam John yeah yeah named
after John the Baptist in Arabic yahia
yes you accepted this way of life that
provides all the answers to life purpose
why you've been here and I opened them
the show with these facts that some
people they're having like most of us
it's a struggle in an of itself life and
the boss is driving him or her crazy
he's become a slave to an individual and
to the paycheck and to materialism and
then the person wakes up one day and
they're like man I'm not happy there's
got to be more they're finally
reflecting all the friends are gone
they're by themselves might have had a
loved one just past his wife left him
after 30 years his girlfriend that he
lived for he was a slave toward she was
a slave to him they broke it off maybe
he's gotten everything so different
circumstances different situations one
got all the money he's still not happy
the other one lost everything and
they're just going in a big circle
wondering now they tune in and they want
to know what do these people have to say
maybe they got the answers what's the
purpose of life right what's it all
about you see brother Eddie the reality
of life that we want to believe is that
money fame power status is going to make
you happy well the statistics show that
the actors and athletes and so on and so
forth that even doctors engineers and
very wealthy people often time are some
of the most depressed people filled with
anxiety their life is not fulfilling
they have a lot of
of things that they're not able to deal
with and that is as simply as you said
it in in in their life they feel
themselves subject or devoted to worldly
things to material things and as human
beings brother we have a creator as all
things on the universe but as human
beings we have this awareness of self of
morality of right of wrong of the impact
of actions of what's good for the world
was bad for the world it's something
built in it's an innate knowledge so in
the Holy Quran we were told in a verse
in the end of so to that yet where he
says well Mahalo to Regina will insert
ilaria boudoir now someone's like okay
you're quoting something I can't
understand what you're saying he said
who's he please tell us for the very
good so the Holy Quran is the final
revelation of God to mankind and in this
revelation it is telling all about the
relationship between God and humans and
then how humans should understand in the
light of God in His will the
relationship amongst themselves so they
could properly arranged their affairs
and deal with each other in peace to
attain this understanding so in that
verse that we recited and we prefer to
recite a verse of the Quran at least
first in Arabic to reference to everyone
that it is preserved in the original
language it was revealed which is
something that is not the luxury of any
other previous revelation you know thing
people's time has changed people's
different versions and so forth and and
so on so the Quran is a very special
book so the verse says to us that God
says I'm newly created human beings for
the purpose of serving me now somebody
might say well that's just you know God
is just seems to be full of himself why
not he's the creator of the universe
what he's saying is is that he is this
all-powerful all-knowing source of
everything he's the absolute truth and
out of all of his creations he is
preferred and given the precedents to
mankind that they know the reality that
they're living in they know right and
wrong they have this creative
intellectualism and this ability to make
the world around them and to build the
world around so he has given us this
innate inherent knowledge so so he says
one up soon warmest Aloha Aloha Mahalo
jajaja taqwa he created the human being
and then he inspired all human beings
what is beneficial to their soul and
what is good for them and that which
will harm them and corrupted condola
hamanaka ha it is a fact true success
true success and success is what makes
you happy when you're truly successful
then you're happy and that is in
purifying vessel that is in taking care
and nurturing this over spiritual food
and remembrance of of God what the car
bomb under sarah and the fact is that
lost and a stray is the one who has
corrupted their soul now i don't mean a
coach Rob but someone says look you know
I've been down that route I used to be a
Christian bar arum for instance the
Bible scholar you know bar Hermes not
sure it'll be okay he's a great Bible
scholar of today's age born-again
Christian and he was look devout but
then for instance many people like him
they dwell deep into their religion
their roots and they said this is
man-made this has contradictions in it
this can't be from God so they put all
religions everything in the same boat
say look this is all man made multiple
Johnson oh yeah you're bringing me back
to this religion thing what you got to
say and and they're thinking that you
know what Islam is just another opinion
it just you know another man-made
religion why should I follow this right
brother see the difference between of
course we have to clarify aslam did not
start in Arabia with the Prophet
Muhammad it was finalized at that point
Islam was being revealed throughout
history all over the world to many many
prophets thousands of profit
for mankind to have some knowledge but
one of the facts of previous prophethood
was that God would reveal a message and
he would test them by saying this
message and its law and his teachings
it's your responsibility to live it and
preserve its meaning in your lives right
because there might be a new prophet
there will be a new prophet that will
come and clarify if people did go astray
well he testified that the Prophet
Muhammad was going to be his final
messenger and so he preserved that
message that he came with which is good
for all peoples and all times in all
places so most people are judging Islam
through the lens of a judeo-christian
experience and that is not a fair
objective judgment yes it's the same God
that revealed those scriptures to those
prophets previously but it the human
beings corruption cannot erase or remove
or distort the actual texts yes they can
interpret them in their own corrupt ways
but the good thing is we have a very
tied in scholarship to it that has a
general orthodoxy and a general
understanding which is very rich and
very flexible that is telling us you
know the understanding as it was passed
down through the generations so Islam if
you take a fair shot at it you will see
that the purpose of life is in getting
to know your Creator how can you serve
someone you don't know like if you're
walking down the street imagine you're
walking down the street and some person
just walks up to you out of nowhere and
says hey can you do this and that for me
now of course it's a personal very
strong faith in mercy compassion and
generosity you're going to try to do
what you can to help them but most
people are on that level what are they
going who you what are you talking about
right but if they're close friend or
their mother or their father their
brother their sister came to them and
asked them can you do this for me they
have this knowledge of that person they
have this closeness they have this
awareness of them in this close intimate
way and it makes them feel much
or obligated to want to serve them in
their request so similarly is the case
if you know God and you've come to know
him through an authentic revelation that
has its proofs you know the Quran is
different from the previous scripture in
that obviously there is no contradiction
in it there is no verse that says this
and then a later verse that says no
that's not the case this is and there's
a very compatible reality between modern
science and and the verses that talk
about the reality of creation in the
part and so there's so much about the
life of the Prophet Muhammad the Holy
part and it was revealed to him that an
objective researcher when they look into
it and we find so many people we find
many great scientists people of
intellect people of you know what was it
the other day Tony Blair's sister-in-law
we embraced Islam she he was the Prime
Minister of England Islam is is being
embraced by people who have this desire
to seek knowledge and try to know the
truth not just people who are looking
for a philosophical way with all due
respect to other religions most people
that convert to Buddhism or Hinduism or
something you know they're just looking
for some philosophical self-help system
of life or whatever they're in some
mystical journey but whereas its labview
you usually find those that come to
islam and really seeking the knowledge
they're really wanting to know who is
God so that I could really serve you tea
party I feel like I can't serve them
whenever I look at the scripture and it
doesn't make sense ambiguous yeah shlom
is clear yeah we're gonna be right back
with more lucid clear explanations of
what the crater wants from us was the
purposes here on the Dean show okay you
got your dream home and you've got your
dream car but you're going to get old
and things are going to happen to you in
your life and then what have you got at
the end of the day is an empty dream
that has no real foundation we are gonna
die
we're going to meet our Lord and he is
going to judge us it becomes an
obligation for each single human being
to find out what the Quran is Islam is
telling us to stay away from things
which are bad for your person embed for
the society back here on the Dean show
with the mom yayuh you came from a
Catholic background born bred and raised
in America you were searching for
purpose of life you went from
Catholicism to born-again Christian and
then you stumble upon Islam and you were
using your mind you were taking an
analytical scientific approach that's
the way we gotta go that's the way we
got to go so you weren't looking to be
an Arab you aren't looking to get you
know into some freak show or something
you were looking for the truth yet and
you found it is that right yes you've
memorized this book the verbatim word of
God the Quran is one of the miracles
that are tangible that people can
investigate look at to see the
scientific proofs that you mentioned
prophecies authenticity it's all in this
car is now my next question is the
person lived 30 years serving their boss
they just got fired now we got their
attention they might get another job
they might start becoming a slave to
somebody else right now the person who
just broke up with Susie Mikey and
they're listening to the country music
and they're getting some solids because
that's all the country music as my lost
my daughter hausa but now why is it so
important that you really take the
matter seriously and you don't just
drift off again and you start going like
a dog chasing his tail you know you go
out life in circles now you just get
another relationship and then you live
for the weekends and then you take her
out you take you know let him take you
out and then again you're just you know
living according to your lusts and
desires accumulating wealth and then
again it's the same thing then you die
and you
live your true purpose in life the way
the crater wanted you to live why is
this so important while we have their
intention they were flickering through
and they tune into the Dean show or a
friend said you got to watch this show
they talk about reality truth why is it
so important you see brother when we
look at people's lives and we look at
the purpose of life we see that people
are engulfed in a material that a lot of
people they have a spiritual and the
reality of what might happen after I die
it seems far away and it makes sense
because even in the arabic it calls the
afterlife and what we're facing
eventually is after all which means far
right duniya means world leading these
clothes do new something close to you
something you can touch so really what a
person needs to weigh out is human
beings are obviously not animals like
others we obviously are superior to
monkeys and we obviously aren't monkeys
and we when we look at this studio we're
sitting in find me bring try to do
whatever you can with any chimpanzee and
develop some sort of ability to do what
we're doing right now at least have a
conversation in the first place so we
are clearly different and special so
somebody needs to think about why am i
different why do I have these abilities
that no no other creature has the
abilities that we have and then they
need to look at creation itself its
creation of some haphazard thing that
just popped up out of nowhere or is it a
bunch of very systematic structured
systems that are functioning all around
the fact of how are how our body digests
food and how the brain works and how the
blood is distributing nutrients and
getting rid of wastes and all of the
different things that are happening
right now the way our eyes are taking
that light bouncing it making everything
how all of that is so very deep in
complex the first thing you need to come
to is how did it get so complex and
clean
really creatively designed not
haphazardly blown up and luckily
everything on planet earth just became
very structured for all this life and
all of these intelligence and so forth
so when we look at that then we look at
the history of the world what is about
God what is the most clear part of
history it's called prophethood prophets
came with miracles throughout history
they did things that blew everybody's
mind and caused them all to become
devout believers and what those prophets
were teaching then what those prophets
taught even in our modern world you know
you have this argument right now should
we have the Ten Commandments and the
court or not of course we should have
them in there well they're saying well
because that's religion well the whole
society's laws are built on religions
laws that came out a long time ago and
so then what's interesting is those same
people if you go in this argument with
them that are struggling with god in all
of this they will admit that they think
that humans made these Commandments and
that there for our benefit right so the
fact is that they are not made by humans
because they come from these prophets we
did these miracles who represent God's
message to mankind and they came and
they established this law and we're all
living don't steal don't kill it's not
of course now society wants to follow us
desire so people are fornicating but
deep down if you ask somebody if your
wife is with someone else if your mom
slept with someone else besides your
father is that okay with you they will
say no they know that that's wrong right
so we have a society that has all of it
right in front of their eyes the
question is are we going to seek for the
deeper purpose or are we just going to
try to be like other animals clearly
we're not like them so we need to
actualize where is the truth about all
this intelligent design that we live
amongst what is the truth about what
we're doing here on earth the fact is
this revelation has said over and over
some people bring the argument they say
well if you say there's a god well then
why is there you know
earthquakes and disasters and people
born with diseases and yes yeah well the
fact is no religion no people that are
attaching themselves to prophethood in
some way whether it be a perfect message
that was purified and preserved as Islam
is a proven fact to be or as other ones
which they even admit amongst their
scholarship that there's been some human
interest in writing and developing of
dogmas and ideas all of them are in
agreement that life is a test and that
life is not perfect in life is not
heaven we are not living in paradise so
we should not expect there to be a
paradise we're living in a test to prove
are we attached to the Creator is our
ultimate devotion to the Creator and in
recognizing that I am grateful to be
created I am loyal to the one that gave
me my life I want to spread the good
that he did and giving me my life he
gave me my life that's very good he gave
me the ability to hear and to see and
all of the fruits and vegetables and
oxygen that I breathe are just
facilitated for me in the world around
me it's so much of a blessing that he
has surrounded around me so am I going
to be grateful am I going to yearn and
seek a relationship with that creator
through an objective research looking in
my heart looking in scriptures looking
at history of course you're being
objective remove myself from the idea
that my culture and my family and our
society's beliefs and the way we must
just think we're not on the day of
judgment going to be judged by our
passport nationality we're going to be
judged and I'm talking to Muslims
through there's Muslims I think they
should be Muslim because their parents
are Muslim and does not make it slim the
right more faith the religion that you
choose should be based upon proofs and
evidences proofs and evidence within the
scripture the text the one who brought
it what it teaches in your heart what's
right and wrong what makes sense when
you put all that together then you
should submit your will to what you know
is going to affect you after you die
because at least within the
judeo-christian
we do believe that God will judge people
because we're responsible for our lives
and so we have a responsibility over
doing the right thing and when we do it
you know there's so many people out
there that did evil bro they did murder
corruption stealing cheating and never
were they accounted for any of that they
just went through the life doing well
that should they just go straight to
heaven where I with all the people who
let a good decent life and kindness and
love and compassion towards others or
should they be accounted for what should
they be purified for what they knew they
were doing wrong and they did not get
accounted in this life similarly there's
people that went out there and spread
goodness and kindness and acts of
greatness to people yet they were never
given any such reward for that we as
people who believe in rewards we give
out Nobel prizes and then we have jails
so this is we all live what's been built
in the system of of recognizing good and
embracing that and and encouraging that
and then rebuking and punishing evil and
bad and corruption so that's something
built into us it is clearly part of a
bigger design of being either God's
people who are people of goodness of
compassion of mercy of a discipline that
says you know what I'm a creative person
like the Creator and I'm seeking to
follow in his light of goodness and
spreading the wellbeing for creation
okay and I'm not a person of destructive
evil corruptive ways which is opposite
and antithesis to a god device when I
took another break and right back with
more on the purpose purpose of life here
in the deed show do you think these
things are going to bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction
it's going to end up causing you if it
hasn't already a lot of pain think
you're happy you're kidding yourself is
really all what we are offering in Islam
what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
are in peace they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
back here on a Dean show we're talking
about purpose is it meant for the
purpose of life to be something nebulous
that now everyone has their opinion you
act someone and so unclear and the
person gets bewildered and they're like
either a why you asking me be I never
thought about it see oh well it's to get
a big house on the prairie raise a
family is to be good to people the other
ones saying this the other ones saying
that it's like multiple choice no one
really can answer lucidly like you did
and we're going to close out we're
almost out of time with what the creator
is saying but is it meant to be
something that's a nebulous unclear it's
like no see that's big us when we're
going back to the fact of history this
is a fact of history this is you know
some people want to say Moses and what
he did Jesus and what he did Mohammed
well that's all see this road tiles or
history okay the same people want to
believe in Alexander the Great and
Stalin and all of those that are they
taking someone as role models yeah yeah
there are the at least are believing in
some part of major impacting history
whenever it suits whatever they decided
to believe for whatever worldly desires
and interests that they have so the fact
is prophethood is a historical reality
God sent prophets province did miracles
not like magic tricks but like sees
partying blind and lepers being healed
by touch moons splitting do they come
with different religions or 11 way of
life a message the problem is that any
of them call people to worship
themselves Saints idols or Jesus see
that's the thing is that we have to in
our research say like for example with
all due respect to all of our brothers
and sisters in Christianity the fact is
is that if you look at the history of
Christianity or Judaism or Buddhism or
Hinduism you will see the development of
major dogmatic beliefs over time and
human beings establishing how we should
finally know like for example with all
due respect because i have many dear
friends and family that are christian
people and they're very good people no
doubt about it the question is
what you're basing your whole eternity
on is that something that stands up to
the test of objective research and
analysis did jesus christ say worship me
I came to die for your sins Diddy so
that's a question that people need to
ask themselves well when you read the
Bible he's worshiping God himself he
fell on his face and prayed he went and
fasted for 40 days why is God fasting if
he's got and so forth right so he's
praying to God he's fasting for the sake
of God he's telling everybody I have no
ability or powers of my own only God is
supporting me and giving me this this
support so they say that in the Bible
that when jesus knew that these Greeks
and the Jewish rabbis are coming after
him that he went and pregnant said Oh
Lord past this cup before me all of the
commentators say this means don't let
these people give me well if he
understood because obviously he's god or
son of God he would know his purpose I
mean obviously wouldn't be in the dark
as to his purpose in life well he should
know he is saying don't let these people
come kill me meaning I don't want to be
killed well if the big hitter comes when
he says a certain prayer once when he's
on the cross it is they have narrated
that he said oh lord why have you
forsaken me so if his whole purpose is
to die for the sins a minute that's what
he wants to do out of his own free will
because that's his gift to the world to
die for their sins why is he saying no
Lord if he's the Lord while who is he
talking to us so these are these are
concoctions by human beings oh god never
taught or the messengers never brought
such ideas what you're saying they when
we're reading the scripture we see some
some contradictory things so that don't
know where did it come from it came in a
place called Nicaea in Turkey three
centuries after jesus clearly people got
confused and so forth and then some
power play from the new Byzantium Empire
with the new Greek ruler of Constantine
who embraced Christianity he wanted to
impose
what what they've understood over there
against what many if you will just look
about the story the history of the
Ebionites FBI nights are historical
people that lived in the Palestine
region Jerusalem Nazareth Bethlehem and
in the surrounding areas of Syria and
Jordan and they always believed that
Jesus was a prophet and he was just the
Messiah who was a special gift sent to
purify the children of Israel from their
corruption and so forth those people
were killed whenever it was established
that you have to believe Jesus is God's
Son of God Trinity died for your sins
this is the belief we all must accept
millions of people got killed they
didn't want to accept that that we're
saying I still believe in Jesus so
political power plays established so
we're being emotionally attached to
something if we look at its history
really it's it's it's it's it's it's not
just this love of somebody who died for
your sin it was a forcing of a political
agenda upon establishing this belief on
people now we are out of time tell us
now I mean I apologize the time is so
short and these episodes go by so quick
so tell us now just in the last minute
that we have you said in the original
it's been preserved tamper free
tamper-proof immaculate ogino in salalah
Abu doon you defined it I have not go
ahead from take it from here we work
what does that mean we were created to
serve God to worship God what does that
mean in the last minute we were created
with a very beautiful blessing that is
intellectual creative spiritual
awareness so we are aware of right and
wrong and we're aware of all these
realities around us on how to deal with
them so what we should do is use our
brains and our hearts to seek God to
come to know him to have a relationship
with him and we must use those two tools
and when somebody comes and says okay
the main thing about God is this and
then you say well that doesn't make
sense you're saying that God in the one
thing that he's blessed you with
intellectual ability he chose to make
his reality something that is not even
graspable of course god is great and I'm
imaginable and beyond our thought but
he's won and he's a creator that's
loving and compassionate and he's not
many he's not you know there's no doubt
about him and his nature amongst amongst
the believers it should not be so we
look to revelation for those answers
last closing comment suggestions I
usually talk to people I say have you
ever asked for guidance many people
again get bewilder stunned shocked or
like no so should that be a start after
the show that they ask and what if they
ask God Almighty will facilitate away
that you know that is the whole purpose
of life to search for the truth as God
asked God pray guide me what's your
purpose yeah good a parade of Mohammed
or jesus the son of the moon who you
talking [ __ ] i want to say great to
anything other than the Creator just the
Creator that's so how can they see if
they don't want to say Allah for
instance or what can they say oh the one
who created me giving something what do
you pray to whatever you know Allah is
an Arabic word that means the god the
worshiped entity we have God we have
those we have hooda we have many words
as long as you don't put a mental
picture yeah as long as you know that's
the creator of the universe and he is
above and beyond anything that your
little human mind can can grasp but his
nature is very clear he's one he is the
transcendental permeating force of
control and power and lordship over this
universe once we recognize that and we
serve that that is what Jesus was
worshipping that is what he was teaching
that was his message Moses Abraham Noah
all the same thing all the same message
all of the same realities other if
people want to get ahold of you you have
a website or you have a yeah well I mean
I have I don't have my own website okay
well we'll have some set up your
biography on the Dean show com maybe we
can add that there we got to go thank
you very much may god almighty the
creative reward you for being with us
and helping to explain purpose purpose
of life thank you and that was it
purpose reflect think about it you live
you die in between a lot of drama and
it's a test of life passed the test of
life and God Almighty has the ultimate
war it's more commodious than any flat
villa luxury palace it's Jenna paradise
and you got to work hard for it plant
seeds of goodness because good breeds
good and when you do good you feel good
and it's all built on that pure
monotheism so ask the creator for
guidance and then you shall receive but
if you don't ask how you're going to
receive and you give us a call 1 866 to
Islam to pick up the verbatim word of
God the Quran or to ask any questions
that you have even criticism give us a
call give us a call don't forget those
will pick up the new dunya to Dean we'll
see you next time God willing peace be
with you